euromaxx highlights and here's your host
Louise Houghton I will welcome to the
show today which starts off with a visit
to the British capital is what's coming
up in the next half an hour trendy Wai
ghin is the number one summer tipple in
London traditional the colorful world of
Swiss wrestling and stylish why white
dinners are a hit the world over gin
used to be known as mother's ruin for
the devastating effects it had on
society in 18th century London later on
it was a favorite for grannies but today
thanks to a crop of aromatic new
concoctions gin is back in town as the
spirit of choice traditionally it's
infused with juniper berries but new
micro distilleries and now introducing
all kinds of flavors and they seem to be
a big hit gin in every imaginable
variety the graphic bar in London's
trendy Soho district is said to have the
world's largest selection there are more
than 200 types
June is a massive thing right now people
are looking for other things other than
vodka you know gin is a flavored vodka
the people just looking for something a
bit more versatile you know more more
flavors out there rather than you know a
nuclear spirit just about every week and
now the new type of gin goes on the
market in Britain gene is booming here
in large part thanks for the work of
many micro distilleries that put out
just a few thousand bottles a year one
of the more unusual is the sacred
micro-distillery located in a private
North London residence it was launched
five years ago by Ian Harte a former
headhunter he started distilling gin in
his own living room and he's still doing
it today but unlike traditional
distilleries heart uses a vacuum process
that's why it looks like a chemistry lab
people are little bits jaundiced if
that's right word with the huge mega
corporations containing who control
everything that they eat and everything
that they drink and to find something
which is artisanal and actually produce
in my case in our own house is a
refreshing change this setup produced
18,000 bottles of gin last year this
year he's planning for 25,000 his
customers now include Fortnum and Mason
the exclusive London department store
and the Tate Gallery of Modern Art parts
trove of treasures so to speak is in his
back garden this is the shuttle we store
all of our botanicals here we have sacks
of Junction and Horace unlike the
traditional manufacturing process heart
distills all of the components
separately and mixes them at the end
that also enables us to change the
recipe so for example for the Tate we
they have their own particular blend and
because we have our distillate stored
separately in the first place that
enables us to offer that take the
ability to blend their own
that limited-edition gene is being
served this summer the Tate Modern has
set up a designer open-air bar featuring
drinks made from its special blend the
cocktail is a work of art you could say
Daniel nokia runs a blog devoted to gym
for the london-based writer high culture
and strong spirits are a natural
combination at its heart is always
better create espera I think its roots
are embedded in creativity and that it's
always experimented with different
botanicals art is the similar thing and
that people bring different experiences
and they bring those different things
together to create what is symbolic of
society and Morel and Moreta towards
society of what people are feeling and I
think it's the same thing with jinns a
day but in the earliest years of its
long history Jin had very little to do
with art on the contrary as we learn at
the Djinn stitute a small Jin museum
based in London's Notting Hill Jeff
burger worked as a bartender for 25
years he's an expert on the history of
gin for much of its past gin drinking
was anything but a convivial pastime
instead it was a rather dispiriting
affair as these old illustrations show
for much of the seventeenth and
eighteenth centuries jim was cheaper
than beer so the poor especially
consumed it in great quantities it
really was an epidemic any given time of
day or night as many as one in for
Londoners was incapacitated for gin
consumption leaving to break down in the
structure of society break down the
family huge increases in chrome certain
areas of the city becoming virtual no-go
areas this time is still very much the
preserve of the peasant classes that
needs of the poor in a city dwellers
in the 20th century gene managed to
become a respectable drink gin cocktails
were especially popular in the 20s and
30s but by the 1960s vodka was ascendant
and gin languished but the rebirth of
the classic cocktail means that gin is
once again in twice a month the graphic
bar even hosts an event called the
Juniper club so on your table with a
little a champagne glass I put some
juniper berries much like a wine tasting
the participants learn to distinguish
between the different flavor notes and
botanicals there are ones are more
floral ones that are more citrusy ones
that are more a little bit spicy when
you mix with tonic it doesn't seem like
a heavy alcoholic drink and now I did
that there's so many flavors and
textures and
and everything just really good the
cocktail connoisseur is agree the Golden
Age of gin has only just begun well in
the same way as London is now known for
its Jin Switzerland is known for its
cheese fondue Alpine landscapes and even
its watches but it's not widely known
for its national sport however the
classical duel is called stringing and
has been around for 700 years and the
events are always held with a strong
sense of tradition this is the schwag of
peak in eastern Switzerland a sporting
event is taking place in a sold-out
arena at the foot of the mountain the
wrestlers are the center of attention
this is one of switzerland's most
popular sporting events the fig Alps
wing it tens of thousands of spectators
have traveled here from far and wide
think the wrestling festival is a
tradition everyone's having fun it's
very nice come from Sweden and we have a
group of friends who try to do
traditional first place what's
interesting are things like the
different types of music the traditional
aspect and of course the restaurant in
it I'm from an Argentine I like the fat
suits wheatland it's great shrinkin is
also known as Swiss rustling the winner
is the competitor who is able to pinned
his opponents back to the floor
about 90 wrestlers are competing for the
crown in this year's fake Alton festival
the highest honor a wrestler can attain
is the title king of shrinkin which is
awarded every three years Arnold for ER
was king of swinging in 2001 he's
considered a favorite to take the crown
here in fig out as he's won at three
times already horror began wrestling at
the age of nine the 34 year old cheese
maker is a small celebrity in his own
right carly fredwardo clearly this is a
home match I live just a quarter of an
hour's drive from here I'd like to win
today it would boost my self confidence
for the championships my voice wrestling
competition is also a community
gathering complete with traditional
dress and rituals
the festival's are big occasions that no
self-respecting politician would dream
of missing Phoenix I've been coming here
for 20 or 30 years it's a piece of Swiss
culture it's not just a sport it's a
tradition and it's one of our Swiss
values shrinkin can look back on over
700 years of history the oldest known
depiction of Swiss wrestling dates from
the 13th century and can be seen in
Lausanne Cathedral in the 19th century
it developed into a very popular sport
thanks to growing media interest Shingen
has developed an even bigger fan base in
the last decade Thomas Ringley has
researched the sport extensively and can
explain why it's so popular as Easter
sporting standing it does in the world
of globalized sport traditional and down
to earth forms of sport are gaining in
appreciation soccer players and the
Champions League earn millions but it's
a different matter in Shingon he calls
after winning on Sunday the champions
have to get up at six o'clock on Monday
morning and go to work as a butcher a
carpenter or a chauffeur dr. Finnian is
a matter of Honor
in the meantime Arnold for is competing
in the final against a fellow team
member the outcome is decided by a
maneuver known as the uber growth for
becomes fake-out champion for the fourth
time in his career in a few weeks he'll
go on to compete in the championships to
decide who will be king and stringent
sring it the swiss sport of the long
tradition and one that's on its way to
becoming more popular than ever well
another event that's become an annual
tradition is a white dinner as the name
suggests everything at this evening
occasion has to be white even the food
the first one was held in Paris 25 years
ago and it has since caught on all
around the world now whilst you might
look a bit lost wearing white in our
studio here the mandatory color recently
lit up a large portion of hamburg harbor
there's only one rule at this party it
has to be white
in Hamburg 6,500 people have turned the
port area into a banqueting Hall
so far as my match it's great as soon as
someone takes out a handkerchief and
waves it everyone else does the same the
mood is so relaxed I interpretado school
awesome i can't even gay and i'll have
everyone's having fun and enjoying
themselves you can ask at other tables
what they're eating and usually taste it
and soon you're talking to pick up
slamming into play if he knows I'm here
for the first time and it's great
muffins for the party must have white
decorations maiya Thompson's in her
kitchen it's her fourth dinner in white
as if ben zeniff I'm a perfectionist and
I think it's fantastic to carry this out
to its proper conclusion mataste a pre
chef to give me I've spent weeks
sometimes even months preparing for
these events and thinking about what to
do to make them special I thought it was
bizarre noses together with her friend
Anya she's preparing her white meal one
dish Asian rice paper rolls colorful
inside white on the outside
it's also a good opportunity to dress up
and her friends profit from her
collection of accessories did you call
me honey let's I had this outfit on last
year and you never wear the same thing
twice despi so this week I shopped for
some new stuff these are the hurts why
meinl shopping name isn't on my mind's
eye hungers would
hours before the dinner participants
flock to the waterside promenade this is
the fourth dinner in white in Hamburg
each time at a different venue
from the start mono boo boo has
organized and registered the event with
the authorities this year she had to
fight for a good venue she announces
over the internet when and where dinner
will be held I'm often asked if I
belonged to a stacked or have political
aims many people say I'm stupid because
I don't want to commercialize it I've
already rejected a lot of money offers
so I'm not doing this for commercial
reasons at all I once supervise a
neighborhood project and got people
together for a good cause and that left
a big impression on me define it's
escaped us by the dinner and white is a
statement a clear statement on
popularizing and democratizing
sophisticated dining earth go open and
goodness in gourmet cuisine rituals play
a role in presenting extraordinary
dishes it's a sign that the customer is
virtually king but there are rituals and
more ordinary meals like picnics and
barbecues
scholarly studies have actually shown
that the greater the anticipation the
greater the enjoyment drinking customs
have developed through history
this is eduardo mushroom eating soup I
find the ritual of raising a glass and a
toast one of the loveliest it comes from
the Middle Ages when the Knights held
their wine goblets in the same hand they
used for their swords or Lance's in
battle at the dining table they believe
themselves vulnerable to show they meant
no harm and wanted to celebrate together
as friends supposed to mediafire at the
white dinner in hamburg people
celebrated together till late at night
the white dress code provides an
additional bond this is really a lovely
event and everyone here is obviously
having a great time
the event comes to an end with a
small-scale fireworks display
participants like sparklers to celebrate
a dinner that turns strangers into
friends
now whenever you visit somewhere new
it's always nice to bring back a
souvenir and in the majority of cities
around Europe you can always find a nice
painting of the skyline and local gift
shops the only problem with these works
of art is getting them home in one piece
however one painter in Istanbul Turkey
has made his souvenir paintings very
easy to carry and that's because they're
seldom larger than my thumbnail mind you
in this case it seems that the small of
the painting the larger the price tag
the Gullah to tower in the heart of
Istanbul vo Lu district painted on Talia
telling the Golden Horn of the Bosphorus
on a thumbtack kiske Lacey her maidens
tower fits on the head of a matchstick
no surface is too small for Turkish
artist Hassan Caillat I out the news
election any other animal these are
objects from daily life that people
hardly ever think about we don't pay
much attention to them way through my
art I want to stress how nice these
things can be and I'm no alone well I
deliberately choose difficult objects we
need to go how small they are or how
well they absorb paint is not so
important what is important is that they
come to life and bring joy to people you
should a Keith didn't pass on Callie's
favourite motif is his home city of
Istanbul
here on a sugar cube while the subjects
remain the same his canvases are always
changing drumstick adore Jesus the goon
Istanbul has a very mystical appearance
it's a city that never sleeps you can
experience something different with
every passing minute people who love
Istanbul love it passionately I thought
I could live here for centuries and
never really know this city when he's
searching for inspiration Hasan Caillat
goes to the place where the modern and
traditional Istanbul meet
the galata bridge it connects the trendy
bay all new and old traditional fattish
districts the tower on the opposite side
is Carly's favorite subject
we look at will look chat I'm at the
gala to tower is part of me and I see it
every day on the way to work when I find
the time to act every few days I go to
the tower and have a coffee you see them
no no take that can no I'm the guzmán an
in de it's ingrained in my memory it's a
part of it been done BTW ebay it's
mainly old Istanbul that Hasan Callie
wants to immortalize in his paintings
the former hajiya Sofia mosque in fetish
district is one such place originally a
cathedral it's now a museum I condom
efficient you can't describe it in words
this building brings different cultures
and religions together it's more than
1,500 years old and today is one of the
city's most visited sites and I'm
dynasty banned by painting motifs like
these but every day I hope to show
people the beauty of histone blood da
foz the in synthetic meet each other
shoulder Callie reproduces this beauty
at home from memory the artist holds his
breath to keep his hand steady it can
take up to three days to complete a
picture just one wrong brush stroke and
the work is ruined this piece is just
half a centimeter long and cost some
4,000 euros the Hagia Sophia on a beam
and I humbly guess that it's just the
greatest what a visitor to Istanbul
looks at my pictures no matter how small
and recognizes Topkapi Palace the baton
sour Hagia Sophia or the college at our
hopes that he do anything that's why
it's hard for me to draw any other city
was that a Wes cookie sheet on the
electro club but Kylie does paint other
things like kemal ataturk the founder of
modern Turkey seen here on a grain of
rice still Hassan colleen never tires of
depicting istanbul weather on a
watermelon seed for a coffee bean
to finish the show today we're taking a
look at the growing number of women in
the gaming industry in fact nearly fifty
percent of gamers in Germany a female
and many of them have flocked to the
gamescom exhibition in Cologne this last
week female developers are also on the
increase and that will encourage women
to play video games all the more because
after all women know what women want
damsels in distress waiting to be saved
by heroic knights in armor or curvaceous
heroines female characters that also
appeal to women are seldom found in most
computer games game designer Cornelia
Gephart and her team are trying to
change that her Berlin company yo my
games works to develop normal characters
with normal figures who wear everyday
clothing i define it came about because
we have a lot of women in our company
and we didn't want to serve up the
typical cliche but we also don't want to
be too extreme and only show really
muscular women or something like that we
want normal people 90 baby born
heightened normal annoyed the characters
are part of the browser game brave
little beasties the game has been online
only for about a month but it's already
a hit among female players
women are making their mark in gaming
around half the 25 million gamers in
Germany are female and they're most
attracted to social network games games
make up a berlin-based internet portal
is also hoping to get more girls into
game design right now only about twenty
percent of game developers are women in
berlin's games academy male design
students are getting more female
competition but the numbers are modest
in 2012 only about a fifth of the
school's new students were female the
school hopes that a new generation of
women will change that one condition is
Anthony see if we could do away with a
lot of cliches me know do meanest people
think it's a man's world but that's
changing and I think society is more
accepting a bit of the existence that's
getting more and more women are playing
games and there's an entire generation
of women who are discovering the
developing games is an interesting job
and not just something for geeks and
geek dink the third wheeler the students
latest game yours truly concentrates on
emotion instead of gameplay let's aside
zanoven ago recently there have been a
bunch of games that feature more
emotional depth but we still think
they're too few of them that's why we
decided to make a game where players can
better experience the emotions of the
games events in an firm come in
discussion
Europe's leading social game developer
Wooga long ago realized that women are
an essential part of the gaming puzzle
Nancy vodka developed diamond dash a
worldwide hit bonide relief when you
think about how 1 million people play
your game each day it's like wow it's
kind of cool he's [ __ ] a donkey about
one-third of Wiggins 280 employees are
female charlotta for Beck is a developer
at Wigan as a female programmer she's
still relatively rare she feels she has
a special contribution to make to the
firm yep as unique as a shoulder slowly
I like to see the big picture and not
just focus on my technical area and make
sure my code is clean my dishes fade so
constantly and I want to make sure my
work fits into the larger context and
has a positive effect yeah it's among
mana of it and he's in full is that's
cool to sprint bougas digital worlds are
cute and there's no violence but
Cornelia gepard from yo my games doesn't
want to miss out on the action even the
game oven I'm a gamer and i really like
fighting games and jump and runs i also
play farmville Oh Pam boo the little
monsters in brave little beasties have
to be fed and taken care of but they can
also fight for Cornelia cupboard it's an
important mix
Bahamas might be a statistic we have
statistics for both monster breeders and
fighters and we can see that the top
breeders tend to be female and the top
fighters are male but both groups like
to play the game being hot FBI ganna
women have already shaken up the game
industry thanks to them the future of
gaming and character design will be more
diverse
and that is all we have time for today
but do join us again tomorrow for a
brand new week of lifestyle news around
Europe for now though from all of us
here goodbye ciao and as we say in
Germany choose
you